[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
une émission pour vous présenter les
initiatives culturelles yvelinoise au
programme aujourd'hui toujours fermée
pour travaux de rénovation le musée
départemental maurice denis se dévoile
en ouvrant et gratuit pour les portes de
son jardin au public deux week-ends de
rendez vous à venir
une visite théâtralisée au château de
thoiry c'est ce que vous propose de
l'association héritage une expérience
immersive pour plonger dans l'histoire
du château
au programme décors costumes et théâtre
et puis le château de rambouillet vous
propose l'exposition vivre à l'antique
de marie antoinette à napoléon 1er est
l'occasion de découvrir à la laiterie de
la reine ou encore la salle de bain de
l'emploi et je vous le disais en titre
toujours fermée pour travaux de
rénovation le musée départemental
maurice denis se dévoile en ouvrant
gratuitement ses portes au public de
façon exceptionnelle toi trois week-ends
de rendez-vous qui ont débuté le 5 juin
dernier
le reportage d'eléonore si nos quais et
mélanie poké l'été n'a pas attendu le 21
juin le musée maurice denis
la statue sans bras d'aristide maillol
prêtés par le musée maillol annonce la
saison à venir
une arrivée qui a poussé les équipes du
musée à ouvrir son jardin pourvu de
grands arbres centenaires
ce jardin il a été aménagé par les
jésuites par une communauté de jésuites
à la fin du 19e siècle dans un terrain
qui existait déjà depuis la fin du xviie
siècle
et quand maurice denis donc le peintre a
acheté cette maison en 1914 il a fait
beaucoup de travaux à l'intérieur de la
maison pour la transformer en habitation
mais par contre il a vraiment respecté
l'esprit de ce jardin spirituelle qui
avait conçu les jésuites avec des
solitudes avec des endroits pour prier
pour les jésuites mais aujourd'hui pour
lire pour rêver laissée à l'état sauvage
depuis trois ans en raison des travaux
intérieurs
les mains vertes du département lui ont
refait une beauté
l'ouverture s'inscrit dans là 18e
édition des rendez vous aux jardins du
ministère de la culture pour ce premier
rendez-vous le musée a confié
des associations autour de la
biodiversité sensibiliser le public
informé faire prendre conscience de
certaines pratiques néfastes et d'autres
bonnes pratiques
c'est très joli c'est très très bon
c'est merveilleux c'est super g 1 est
beau mais avec à tous les stands c'est
informatif et éducative à on a beaucoup
appris sur les composts le jardin du
musée maurice denis accueille du public
les deux prochains week-ends l'entrée
est gratuite mais les réservations sont
fortement recommandés pour les
animations au programme fabrication de
peintures naturelles compte susanna ou
encore une conférence découverte autour
de la statue d'aristide maillol une
visite théâtralisée au château de thoiry
c'est ce que vous propose de
l'association héritage les samedis à 12
et dimanche 13 juin
objectif promouvoir la culture auprès
des jeunes une expérience immersive donc
ou 22 acteurs de l'association vous
plongeront dans l'histoire du château
au programme décors costumes et théâtre
regarder une visite théâtralisée en fait
c'est c'est une visite du château mais
qui sort un petit peu des codes
habituels on n'est pas simplement sur
une visite guidée où on va voilà nous
présenter les différents objets d'une
caisse ou simplement l'histoire
en fait là on a une vraie mise en
ambiance
on part de la renaissance ou donc c'est
le comment commanditaires le tout
premier à avoir habité ce château est l
avoir fait construire en fait ils ont
fini seconde guerre mondiale où c'est
donc le père le grand père du
propriétaire actuel en fait donc donc
voilà on traverse vraiment les
générations est vraiment que le public
puisse se plonger en fait dans
l'ambiance donc on a des costumes de
chaque époque on a des décors les
dialogues ont été travaillés adapté avec
les informations concernant chaque
période et c'est donc c'est vraiment une
plongée dans l'histoire en fait les
visites sont réalisés au profit de la
restauration du château de thoiry
réservation via le site du château et ce
week end là vont en scène vous présenter
les voix ont le blues du rock un concert
de fin d'année des adhérents de
l'atelier concert de l'association
une dizaine de chanteurs viendront à
jouer sur scène ça se passera samedi 12
juin à 20 heures à l'espace alphonse
daudet est de coignières le thème de ces
dames cette année vous l'aurez compris
c'est le blues et le rock dans les
classiques on attend le second rang on a
tiré au cuir a donc on essaye vraiment
varié français anglais
voilà on a du tuning c'est vraiment un
maillage on est sur un univers blues
puis rock et on va s'amuser un petit peu
a passé voilà faire un passage entre le
12 et le rock et réservations à faire
via le site elle avoue en scène d'autres
spectacles à venir dans les yvelines
après ces deux premiers volets leçon
d'histoire de france maxime d'aboville
revient au théâtre du vésinet avec la
révolution un spectacle donc sur la
révolution française où l'artiste vous
fera vivre l'événement il aura lieu le
lundi 14 juin à 20h30
et puis le théâtre alexandre dumas vous
propose de découvrir le spectacle
romanesque un voyage sur les traces de
la langue française et sa transformation
au fil des ans le spectacle aura lieu
mercredi à 16 juin à 20h30 chronique des
jours qu'ovide 19 10
c'est le titre de la collection d'une
trentaine d'oeuvres composé par et mao
le peintre et emmanuel ce corail qui est
écrivain s est agacé vous sega tsongo
pardon square va
cette collection unique et donc va être
mise en vente par art partage point com
qui est donc une société qui est basée à
montigny le bretonneux
oui c'est ça la chronique des jours
qu'ovide 19 days est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre ces deux artistes
que vous venez de citer justin en fait
cette chronique présente de nombreux
portraits de femmes et d'hommes qui ont
plus ou moins subi la crise sanitaire
toujours accompagnée d'un texte qui
contextualise le portrait ce sont des
médecins les infirmières avec la main ce
sont des personnes de tous les jours ce
sont des enfants des tablets en les
plaçant dans toutes sortes de vie qui
subit quelque part cette histoire du v8
clic et qui a complètement ont valu le
monde et donc comment eux ces chroniques
ont débuté ces liens l'irl aventure
commence le 8 avril lorsque et mao le
fait le portrait de la reine
d'angleterre après sa prise de parole
concernant la crise mondiale intitulée
the queens speech l'oeuvre fait le buzz
sur la toile et incite donc les deux
artistes à concevoir cette collection
c'est vraiment une collaboration très
interactive déjà dans la conception et
la création de l'oeuvre
on est dans une co-construction on
arrive déjà à voir à l'oeuvre et en même
temps que l'oeuvre a été réalisée
je m'empare est du travail pour cette
fois-ci construire le texte qui allait
accompagner et comment va se passer à la
vente
eh bien c'est la société impulsion
portant le concept d'art partage point
com qui s'occupera de la vente
le but justement d'art partage points
comme mettre en lien des artistes et des
entreprises et démocratiser l'accès à
l'art dans tous types de sociétés
la vente des puits draps débutera donc
que dans les prochains jours chaque
oeuvre va être mise en scène vers un
univers et cet univers donc ce avec une
exposition en ligne quelques pas avec
une mise à disposition du catalogue
puisque on a préparé nous avons préparé
un catalogue en français et en anglais
donc on peut d'ores et déjà retrouver la
collection sur le site internet
art partage points comme voilà il faut
la retrouver ici et puis sur le site
internet aussi c'est noté et donc petite
particularité 30% du montant de ses
ventes donc seront reversés à
l'association l'association solidarité
avec les soignants oui c'est ça en fait
ce qui équivaut à plus ou moins à 5000
euros reversés à l'association qui a été
créée en mars 2020 par anne roumanoff et
jean pierre bansard solidarité avec les
soignants vise à améliorer l'équipement
des salles de repos des soignants merci
célia gars tsongo journalistes pour tv
78 d'avoir été avec nous vivre à
l'antique 2 marie antoinette à napoléon
1er c'est l'exposition qui est
actuellement exposé au château de
rambouillet depuis mi mai l'occasion
pour les visiteurs de découvrir la
laiterie de la reine ou encore la salle
de bain de l'empereur napoléon 1er nous
sommes allés sur place avec bérengère
bourgoin regarder montrer la
transmission de l'antique sur le moderne
c'est le but de l'exposition vivre à
l'antique de marie antoinette à napoléon
1er une cinquantaine d'oeuvres datant de
1780 à 10 815
ils sont présentés le but de
l'exposition vivre à l'antique de marie
antoinette à pau lyon 1er et de montrer
l'importance de la redécouverte de
l'antiquité à la fin du xviiie siècle et
au début du 19e siècle et toutes les
répercussions que ça a pu avoir dans la
vie quotidienne comme dans le domaine
artistique ou voire sociale l'exposition
met en avant deux espaces en particulier
la salle de bain de napoléon ainsi que
la laiterie de marie antoinette le point
de départ de l'expo était vraiment deux
espaces phare dans le dans ce domaine
qui est la laiterie de la reine que vous
voyez ici et la salle de bains de
l'intérieur ces deux espaces où on
essaie de recréer le monde antique dans
une sortie sphère intime des souvent et
donc avec l'expo on voulait comprendre
mieux pourquoi et comment
au fin du xviiie siècle ils ont commencé
à régine et le présent à l'image du
passé lointain sur place tableaux
maquettes porcelaine de sèvres
l'exposition à bénéficier du prêt d'un
panorama
de la ville de rome l'exposition
permettra au public de voir de
nombreuses maquettes de monuments
antiques qui ont été réalisés au xviiie
siècle des peintures quelques sculptures
des éléments en porcelaine également
produites par la manufacture de sèvres
principalement quelques oeuvres de
l'antiquité également je pense à un vase
assez monumentale issus de fouilles
archéologiques quelques éléments de
mobilier de décors intérieurs qui datent
de cette époque également l'exposition
va durer trois mois et sera disponible
jusqu'au 9 août le château de
rambouillet fait d'ailleurs partie à des
monuments nationaux d'île de france
participant au printemps des monuments
ce week-end pour l'occasion 50 monument
partout en france proposeront des
animations dont les yvelines c'est le
château de maison à maison laffitte la
villa savoye à poissy et donc le château
de rambouillet qui participent à
l'événement au programme expositions
théâtre jeux et musique plus
d'informations sur le site des monuments
nationaux
et c'est la fin de ce numéro du 7-8
culture merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve mardi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de cette culture et d'ici
là
portez vous bien
[Musique]